Uh, let's bring up Muslim speaker.
Muslim speaker, you're on stage. How you
doing?
>> Hi. Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you.
>> Okay, man. How are you, man?
>> Pretty good. Pretty good.
>> That's good, sir. So, can I have a
question?
>> Well, you have to answer the question
first.
>> It's based on the thing you just said.
Um,
>> like I said,
>> you made a specific claim that
>> I Muslim speaker, like I said, you can
ask whatever you want after we deal with
the topic.
>> Okay. Sure. Okay. What message Paul
corrupt or contradicts? Okay. Sure. So I
take the position that Paul is the the
person who basically like um how would
you say like um increased the status of
the cru of the crucifixion. I would take
the position when it comes to the
crucifixion like specifically to James
the the brother of Christ. I would take
the position that Paul um simply raised
the status and James if it was important
he would have talked about with inside
of his um according to his scripture
which he written. Correct? No. So what
I'm a little confused what what message
are you saying that Paul corrupted or
contradicted?
>> Yeah, I'm take I take the position that
he just simply raised the um the status
of the crucifixion. Meaning he corrupted
the true meaning of the crucifixion.
>> Okay. Where do we get the true meaning
of the crucifixion?
>> Yeah. Again I could just appeal to my
>> Okay. So in the Quran you get the true
meaning of the crucifixion.
>> Can I tell you what?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Sure. So when it comes to the
Quran itself, it simply states that
again that the Quran is a criterion over
the previous scriptures. Correct?
>> No,
>> it doesn't.
>> No.
>> Okay, no problem. Can you make me clear?
>> Uh, no.
>> So, just a quick question.
>> Um, what's the term furan mean?
>> Criterion.
>> Oh, so it's a criterion, correct?
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, but you said before you saw it.
>> No, I said it's not a criterion over the
previous scriptures.
>> Well, correct. Wait one second. Wait,
what's according to the verse uh chapter
free? Uh free free verse, right? Okay.
When the term is used, just a quick
question. What's he referring to? Sorry.
A criterion over.
>> It doesn't say a criterion over any
books.
>> Should we read the verse?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. I'm I'm curious. Have you ever
watched my channel before or anything on
me?
>> Yeah. Personally, your claims are
terrible. No offense,
>> but it's okay, man.
>> You said you said my That's fine. I
don't I don't mind your opinion, but
>> Okay, sir. you're uh you said that
you've watched me before and my claims
are terrible.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Um and and this is the argument you're
bringing to me.
>> I mean, sure. Yeah. If we can establish
that the Quran is simply a criterion
over the past scriptures,
>> then the crucifixion according to the
Quran should be the objective truth.
Correct.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. No problem. So, we can establish
this. Okay. Then you would have
>> Yeah, you're right. So, chapter 3:3 and
four.
>> Sure. Go to
>> All right. You're actually okay that
that um you didn't stick with your
argument before. So I think next time we
should go after after we've established
this.
>> Yeah, let's go to that.
>> Nice. Okay, let's let's go to that next
position after.
>> Okay,
>> let's go to Quran. Let's go to Quran.
>> All right, so chapter 3 verse 3 and 4 it
says he has sent down upon you the book
in truth confirming what was before and
he revealed the Torah and the Gospel.
>> Nice.
>> Uh reading. What's wrong with this
freaking website, man?
>> Keep on reading, bro. It's good. By the
way, you don't need to appeal to
>> Oh, you can again I don't take the the
English translations authority. Good.
>> Appeal to the Arabic.
>> No, I I agree because according to this
Yeah, I'll put it. You read Arabic?
>> Not fully, but I know what the term
criterium is.
>> Okay, cool. So, yeah, cuz uh this one
actually butchers it. It says, "And he
revealed the Quran." It doesn't say
that. It says he revealed al he revealed
the furan the criteria. Guess the
criterion correct.
>> Yeah. So that got that wrong.
>> We can establish that the Quran is a
criterion. Correct.
>> No. Well, it is a criterion, but in this
verse here, it doesn't refer to the
Quran as
>> No, stay just stay right here where it
says those who who like disbelieve
um the revelation of Allah. What's it
referring to?
>> It says, "Lo, those who disbelieve the
revelations of Allah, theirs will be a
heavy doom Allah is mighty able to
requite."
>> Stay there. No. Stay right there. So the
disbelievers are going to be the people
who reject the criterion. Correct.
Meaning the
>> Well, no, they they it says those who
disbelieve the revelations. So
>> sure. So they disbelieve
that will be that'll be the Quran.
That'll be the Torah. That'll be the
Gospel and that'll be the criteria.
>> No, don't lie. Don't lie. The criterion
is established.
>> Wait, it's established?
>> What? What's the criterion here?
>> Yeah, the Quran. Yeah, it's going to be
referring to the Quran. Look in the
Wait, wait, hold on. Hold on a second,
brother. Hold on. Okay.
>> Yeah, go ahead. Where does it say that
the Quran is the criterion here?
>> Sure. Let's context you. Let's read from
the start.
>> Okay, let's read from the start.
>> Okay, let's start. Okay,
>> back. So, it's chapter 3.
>> Okay.
>> He has revealed unto you
>> the scripture in with truth confirming.
So, wait. What scripture is that?
>> Which is what?
>> I'm I'm asking you
>> the Quran.
>> All right. I agree. That's the Quran.
>> Nice.
>> So, he revealed to you the scripture and
truth which is the Quran confirming that
which was before it.
>> Nice. Even as he revealed the Torah and
the gospel.
>> So the Quran is mentioned, the Torah is
mentioned, and the gospel is mentioned,
right?
>> No. Yeah. One second. The criterion is
established as the the the revelation
revealed to the prophet.
>> Wait, where does it say that?
>> In the verse you just read, the verse in
which he says it.
>> Okay, hold on. Where does it say that
the that the uh book the scripture given
to the prophet is the criterion? Where
does it say that in verse three?
>> It's referring to the revelation which
is being revealed to the prophet. But
where does it say we have revealed unto
thee Muhammad the scriptural truth
confirming that which so it's not saying
that the criterion is the Torah in the
gospel. What it's saying is the Quran is
the criterion which confirmed the
previous scriptures.
>> Slow down. Slow down. Slow down. You you
said that you appeal to the Arabic,
right?
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
>> Okay, that's good. Does it does the word
um does the word criterion pop up in
verse three at all?
>> In verse three?
>> Yeah.
>> What? Well, I mean, it's not
establishing that surely now.
>> So, the answer is no.
>> No, but
>> Okay. Thank you. So, so it says
>> that doesn't mean anything.
>> Slow down.
>> Sure.
>> It says that the scripture that Muhammad
was given is a confirmation of the
previous scriptures. The
>> Can you can you read Can you read verse
four?
>> I'll read it in a second. We got to
establish three first. Okay.
>> Yeah, I already did.
>> So, verse three,
>> criterion is going to be appealing to
the Quran.
>> Okay. So in verse three it says the
Quran confirms the Torah and the Gospel,
right?
>> Yeah. The criterion confirms.
>> Okay. Hold on. Where does it say the
criterion confirms? Where does it say
that?
>> I'll tell Can I tell you?
>> Yeah. In verse three.
>> Nice. Okay. I'll tell you. Okay. So, if
you keep go to verse one for me, I'll
read it for you.
>> I'm in verse three. Where in verse three
the criterion is? We need to establish
what the criter you said. You said my
brother. I don't want to have to mute
you. Let's Let's
My bad, sir. It's all good. You said you
said that in verse three it says the
criterion
confirms the previous scripture.
>> I said the criterion is a pres is
presupposed that it's going to be
according to the Quran because
>> verse four.
>> Okay.
>> Read verse four.
>> So wait, just to be clear, you're saying
verse four says the Quran is the is the
criterion, right?
>> He's going to Yes. The four correct.
Yes.
>> Let's read verse four again. So it's not
in verse three. Let's see verse four.
>> So verse four,
>> nice.
>> Let let me I'm going to read them back
to back. So to just to continue the
flow. Okay.
>> So he has revealed to you the scripture
with truth, confirming that which was
before it, even as he revealed the Torah
and the gospel.
>> Correct.
>> Time for a guidance to mankind
>> and has revealed the criterion.
>> Nice.
>> What is identif
I'll keep reading. Okay, good.
>> Look, lo, those who disbelieve in
disbelief, the revelations
of Allah,
>> correct?
>> There will be a heavy doom
mighty and blind. So, the revelations
does it say in the criteria.
>> Can I tell you? Can I tell you? Okay.
>> Yeah, please.
>> Okay, no problem. So, again, it doesn't
say criterians.
It says criterion. So, it's going to be
referring to a singular. Now, let me
finish. Let me finish. It's I'll tell
you I'll tell you again. Just listen to
me very closely. When it says about the
people who disbelieve on the revelations
of Allah, it's simply referring to the
people who do not know the rights and
the wrongs upon to the revelations.
That's the whole point. The criterion is
simply telling what is right and wrong
onto the people who disbelieve on the
Torah and the Injil. Again, we can
establish this when according to the
tough says and also we can appeal to
chapter 5. Are you willing to go to
chapter 5, Avery?
>> No, I want to stay right here because I
I'm I'm I'm just a little confused.
Earlier you told me that the verse says
that the Quran is the criterion. You
said it in verse three and then you
backtracked and said, "Okay, no, it's
not in verse three." When I pressed you
on it, then you said it's in verse four.
So when we went to verse four and I read
it, still it doesn't identify which of
the revelations of Allah is the
criterion.
>> Let me finish. I let you talk, did I
not?
>> Sure. Yeah. No problem.
>> Okay. So yet what we see here is it says
now it starts talking. It says, "Lo,
behold, look, check it out what I'm
about to say. Those who disbelieve in
the revelations plural of Allah, theirs
will be the a heavy doom." Where does it
say which of those revelations are the
criterion? What does it identify here?
That's the
>> Okay, no problem. Yeah. So, what you're
simply asking is basically just to prove
that the criterion is the Quran. And if
I do that, then you can establish that
the then you would have to concede to
your point. Correct.
>> In verse four, establish that the
criterion is the Quran in verse four.
>> Okay. Sure. Wait. So, and if I prove
that, then you would concede. Correct.
>> If you if you prove that, then you got
me. Oh,
>> wait. You put your word on it.
>> Yeah, you got me in in verse four. If if
it says the Quran is their criterion,
you got me.
>> Okay, no problem. Just say okay, that's
fine. Let's go to Wait, you want to go
to uh cross references or
>> I have the I have the verse up.
>> Correct. Also, cross references.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You have another another
kuran vers. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, let's go to it. I'm pretty sure
you already know it, so you might as
well turn it up. You know the verse I'm
appealing to anyway?
>> I don't know. You could be appealing
anything.
>> Okay, sure. Let's go to it. Um,
one sec. I get up. I'm able to put on my
screen or do you want to do one?
>> You can just tell me what verse it is.
I'll pull it up for us.
>> Okay. Sure. One sec. I'm just hold it
was like chapter. Yeah.
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. We can just simply Yeah, we can
appeal to uh chapter 5.
>> Chapter 5 verse what? 48.
>> Uh 44. 44.
>> 44. Okay. Chapter 5 verse 44. All right.
So chapter 5:44 is about to tell us that
the Quran is the criterion of chapter 3.
>> It's going it's going to it's going to
elaborate on why I take the position the
criterion is going to be for the Quran.
Correct. Yeah.
>> No. See, brother,
>> one second.
>> I'm going to let you work. I'mma let you
work. I'm going let you do your thing.
So here's here's chapter 5 verse 44,
guys.
>> Okay. You're laughing. I know. It's like
the biggest nervous laugh ever, man.
>> Okay. Whatever you say, big dog. Here's
the verse, guys. We did reveal the Torah
wherein is guidance and light by which
the prophets who surrendered judged the
Jews and the rabbis and the priests um
by such of Allah's scripture as they
were bidden to observe. I guess so
judged. I see why they put that in
parenthesis cuz it didn't make sense
without it. And there unto where were
they witnesses. So fear not mankind, but
fear me and my revelations for uh and my
revelations for a little gain. Who so
judges not by that which Allah has
revealed, such are disbelievers. Read up
to 47. 47.
>> All right.
>> That's the reason that's the reason I
asked you to start on that cuz we're
going to get on the full context so we
can understand. So you can't like say
that the the criterion isn't everything.
>> Okay. But remember you do you you would
grant me my paradigm when it comes to
taps. Correct? Just as I would do when
it comes to church fathers.
>> No, you have to justify your position. I
don't care what anybody say.
>> Correct. And I'm able to appeal to taps.
Correct.
>> The taps has to have a justification.
>> Correct.
>> For example, if our just says something,
it better be based on what the Quran
already said, you know.
>> Correct. Yeah. But like in order for you
to disprove the taps, you would have to
show me over evidence in order to
justify your position.
>> Well, yeah, I use the Quran. You you can
use whatever taps you want. I'm going to
use
>> Okay, no problem. No problem. So, when
it comes to your biblical text, I'll use
the same standard. Continue.
>> Probably go with that.
>> Sure.
>> And we prescribe for them life for life,
eye for an eye, nose for nose, ear for
ear, tooth for tooth, yada yada yada.
But who also so forgoeth uh it
>> goes 47.
>> All right. 47. Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
therein. Who so judges not by what Allah
has revealed. They are the wrongdoers.
>> No, stay there. Stay there. Just like
Okay. In order to like judge in like
between with what Allah has revealed to
them, you would have to have the
criterion. Correct? Because remember
because therein is basically trying to
say that in order to judge by what there
is, you would have to use the criterion.
Correct?
>> It says what they have is the criterion.
>> No even talking about the criterion. I'm
trying to say in order to know what what
is there in we would have to use the
criterion in order to like like in order
to understand.
>> No. They're saying what they have is
their criterion. That's
>> so what is therein? Tell me what what
does it mean by therein?
>> The gospel. The gospel. What's Okay, one
second. So we can establish that the
criterion is not the gospel. Now we've
now we're only Yeah. The criterion
obviously according to chapter 3:4.
Okay. Remember this as well?
>> According to Yeah. Can I finish?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So when in accordance to
chapter 3:4, it literally referring to a
criterion over the the revelations.
Correct.
>> No, it never said that. Where does it
say that? Where does it say that there
was a where in verse four does it say
that this is a criterion over the rest
the other revelations? Where does it say
that?
>> Okay. Wait one second. So what does it
tell me? What does it say then?
>> Oh my. Do we have to keep going back and
forth on this?
>> Oh yeah, of course. Because yo
>> read it again. Okay. Look. Look. I'mma
read it again. I'll put it on the
screen. Let me matter of fact, let me
make it big on the screen so you make
sure you can see it yourself. All right.
Should be big enough. I'm going to read
this. Stop me when you hear the words
and the criterion over the other
revelations. Stop me when you hear that.
>> Wait a second. It has to be Wait, it has
to be the those exact words.
>> That's what you said it says.
>> Well, correct. Yeah, I was like um for
example, um how would you say it?
Paraphrasing. Paraphrasing like the
overall
>> You're not even You're you're not
paraphrasing. You're just literally
misquing. You're It doesn't say
anything.
>> That's incorrect. Yeah. Can I tell you
why? It says uh so that he revealed the
Torah and the gospel of for time as
guidance for mankind and he has revealed
the criterion.
>> Where does it say the criterion over the
Torah and gospel or over the other
revelations? It doesn't say that.
>> Okay. All right. Stay there. Okay. No
problem. So just just a quick question.
It's like a clarifying question. These
revelations who it's referring to, is it
going to be referring to the Torah and
also the Injil?
>> It refers to all of them.
>> Is it going to be referring to the
Quran? Quran, Torah, Zabor, Injil, books
of Abraham, all of it, all the
revelations of Allah.
>> It's referring to the people who reject
the the I mean, basically the Quran and
the
you did it again. Where does it say
those who reject the Quran? Where does
it say that?
>> Yeah, I appeal Wait a second. Why are
you appealing to an exact word fallacy
every time? You're not going to get away
with it. Like I know Sam Shampoo can do
that, but you let me tell you the
problem. Let me let me tell you the
difference between you and I, my friend.
The difference between you and me is I
am just literally reading the Quran word
for word and sticking to what the Quran
says word for word. You are not. You're
adding to and taking away from what the
Quran says and you're saying, for
example, you make statements like the
Quran said this. And so I say, okay,
where does it say that? And you said you
say you say does it have to say that?
>> Yeah. One second. It says
>> you clarified. I clarified that's the
overall conclusion. That was just a
paraphrase.
>> So look, do this. Do this for me. Stop
saying the Quran says something when it
doesn't say it. Okay. Because when you
>> Yeah. contextually it does say that.
Yeah.
>> Okay. Exactly. When it says those who
disbelieve the revelations of Allah.
What are the revelations of Allah?
>> Yeah. So yeah, it's going to be
referring to the Torah and the In.
>> Awesome. Also, what else is that? It
>> Yeah, it's not Yeah, it's not going to
be referring to the Quran because it's
established that the Quran is simply the
criterion over these past scriptures,
>> brother. Is the Quran one of the
revelations of Allah?
>> Correct. But this is Yeah, but it's
establish one of the revelations of
Allah.
>> Wait, can I can I respond? Okay,
>> please. Just
>> Yes. Yes. Like just just I'll tell you.
I'll tell you. I'll tell you. So, Bro,
let me finish. Bro, why are you so
shook? Let me finish. Brother, I think
that you're shook and you don't you
don't even realize you have no sense.
>> You wish you rejected you wish you
rejected that means criteria and then
you back back like fall back by
so this dude is saying you're saying
those who disbelieve the revelations of
Allah
>> it's only talking about the Torah and
gospel. So the correct revelations of
Allah
>> I never never said that. Never said
that. What am I hearing? I I literally
never said it's literally established in
in verse three. Why are you coping?
You're coping so hard. It literally says
it.
>> That's a nice try. That's That's cute.
>> It's like the It literally says to
>> What else does it say? Does it say the
Quran?
>> Yes, it says the Quran's a turn over the
revelations.
>> Okay.
>> This guy's coping over. I'm going give
I'm going to give you one last be
honest. I'm going to give you one last
chance to be honest. I'm going to read
this verse. Tell me when you hear the
words, "The Quran is a criterion over
the Torah and Gospel."
Oh my. the Torah and gospel. He revealed
a fourth time as a guidance for mankind.
And he revealed the criterion.
>> Sure.
>> I don't Oh, you didn't stop me. Those
who disbelieve in the revelations of
Allah, theirs will be a heavy doom.
>> Did it say anything? Oh, stop. Stop. Did
it say anything?
>> Did it say anything about the Quran
being a criterion over the Torah Gospel?
Did it say that?
>> Okay. Yeah, I'll tell you. ordance. I'll
tell you in accordance
I'll tell you. Can I tell you? Can I
tell you? Can I tell you? Can I tell
you?
>> Okay, no problem. No. Yeah, I'll tell
you. I'll answer the question to you.
Yeah. Yes. It's the subw that the Quran
is a criterion.
>> Take care of yourself. You're an
absolute liar. The joke. A dimwit.
Muslims will lie on their own book, lie
on their own Quran. I gave you a chance
to be honest. You guys act like we don't
have the verse on the screen. Do we not
have the verse on the screen? We're
reading it together. All 2,800 of us.
All 2,800 of us. 3,300 if you count Tik
Tok. We are all looking at the verse on
the screen. We're reading it over and
over and over again. The second this
dude says, "Yeah, the Quran says this."
I ask, "Where does the Quran say that?"
He responds with, "Why does it have to
say that?" because you said it says it.
So when I challenge you and press you on
what you say the Quran says, I'm wrong
for holding you to your words. That is
insane. Like like guys, you only you got
to be a Muslim to do this. You got to be
a Muslim to do something like this. To
have this level of of oh man, what what
what's what is the word like what's
another word for like lack of
self-awareness? What is that? What is a
word? I don't know. But to be that
unaware of your of what you're saying of
of how you're reasoning, your method, it
is it is demonic. I'm telling you, it's
not human. It's demonic. Insane. Insane.
He told me that he was going to prove to
me that the criterion in chapter 3 is
referring to the Quran. And in to to do
that he went somewhere else to chapter 5
that said nothing about the criterion
but went to the verse that says let the
people of the gospel judge by what Allah
has revealed in it in the gospel. No
it's not it's not talking you need the
you need a criterion. According to the
Quran they have the criterion. They have
to judge by the gospel. That's their
criterion. No. No man. Get out of here
man. You you don't know what you're
doing dude. You have no idea what you're
doing. Goodness gracious.